also es gibt ja ein oster paket des
bundeswirtschaftsministers habeck wo
drin geschrieben steht wie viel
windkraftenergie bis 2030 aufgebaut
werden soll 51 mitarbeiter nicht glauben
so wenn das stimmt dann brauchen wir
ungefähr 60 bis 70 gaskraftwerke um das
backup zu machen wenn der wind nicht
weht diese gaskraftwerke müssen erstens
geplant werden zweitens gebaut werden
und drittens brauchen wir auch genug gas
über 100 rennen auch verstromen kann
wenn der wind nicht weht es heißt das
backup-system gas ist ein ganz
wesentliches system steht wir im moment
aber stehen hier völlig auf dem schlauch
weil unsere lieferkette sozusagen
zusammengebrochen ist obwohl alle immer
dafür gewesen sind auch im bundesrat
auch die grünen als frau merkel dann
sagt der atomstrom aus kohle steigen aus
dann brauchen wir das backup-system gas
jetzt ist mein szenario die ganzen leute
die gas fördern und verkaufen könnten
die müssen natürlich erst mal ihre
produktionskapazitäten erweitern und wer
wirtschaft bescheid weiß der weißen
rauchs planung da muss die infrastruktur
gebaut werden bis das so weit geht das
heißt man kriegt es nicht im september
oder oktober man kriegt vielleicht in
zwei drei jahren wir haben also kein
backup system für den weiteren ausbau
der windkraft und die windkraftanlagen
werden jetzt geplant und keiner weiß ob
sie ein paar jahren sich trainer nicht
na ja und wo sie stehen sollen ja weil
die zwei prozent jedes bundesland
verfügung stehen sollen müssen ja erst
durch gerichte und gerichte jan peters
naturschutzflächen schon jetzt aktiv
ausbauen wollen heißt alle nicht elon
musk weil wie schnell es gehen kann ja
er wird plant haben wir jetzt hier vor
den toren berlins mit dem ein punkt ist
eigentlich dass die energiewende mit
wind und solar im moment augenblicklich
aktuell tod ist weil wir das problem
nicht lösen können wir können das backup
system nicht haben eine batterie die man
wir bräuchten riesenbatterie gefüge um
das alles zu speichern wenn man sich
über das gas im vorfeld speichert
sozusagen muss demnach fällt speichern
dann braucht man die batterien die
größte steht glaube ich in australien
die hat der kapazität von 0,3 oder so
megawatt irgendwas in der größenordnung
0,13 glaube ich so und dann bräuchten
wir ja hunderte von diesen batterien um
dieses die sachen vorzuhalten für die
ich weiß nicht genau wie das alle das
ist ein befehl das ist ja immer so als
wenn der fünfköpfige familie sagt wir
wir verkaufen jetzt mal unseren
elektroherd ja weil wir in der
mikrowelle kriegen allerdings erst in
einem jahr oder umgesehen aber nicht ob
sie funktioniert machen es schon mal das
ist schwierig oder
bei dem vergleich hier weil der klub ja
absolut weil wenn man habe also unserem
wirtschaftsminister ganz genau zuhört
dann sagte er wir werden die nächsten
vier fünf jahre lang gasknappheit haben
das heißt das problem bleibt ja eine
ganze weile gleichzeitig sagte na ja ak
w das lohnt sich jetzt gar nicht mehr
für diesen winter hilft uns das nicht
naja aber wenn es ja 45 jahre sind dann
brauchen wir auch die nächsten 45 winter
eventuell noch strom und heizung und da
könnten andere energiequellen doch
helfen und mittels offizieren ja ich hab
ich auch so ich musste also die
unbedingt diversifiziere unterschlagen
alles laufen lassen gucken dass wir über
die runden kommt und alles weitergeht
damit nicht noch größere schaden
entdeckt und dann wenn man sagt ja
atomkraft kann man nicht nehmen die
marken athene wir haben aber dann
verbraucht man kein gas und strom zu
erhalten und das kann man dann in die
wärme sagte hermenau sie waren ja bei
den grünen hat
sich dafür entschieden sie haben sich an
meiner fans richtig was denken sie denn
heute über die grünen also es gibt
manchmal putzige themen wo ich immer
nicht so richtig weiß was soll also ich
bin beim handwerksmeister und jetzt auch
er hat nicht mal weibliche lehrlinge und
sollte triplette einbauen und das ein
bisschen skurril aber das lasse ich mal
jetzt weg ist das ein ablenkungsmanöver
im wesentlichen bin ich zum beispiel
dafür dass wir uns mehr energie autark
hier organisieren auch mit erneuerbaren
natürlich ich bin auch dafür dass wir
keine gifte in kinderspielzeug wir
können viele themen auch führen die ich
also so einschätzen was wir ein bisschen
komisch vorkommt ist dass dieser ganze
rizzo umkrempelung der gesellschaft von
oben auf so rein diktiert wird die
gesellschaft buch das geht alles nicht
rapp geraden beispiel mit den batterien
den gaskraftwerken aufgemacht und dann
sind die ent alle tabs nazis oder sonst
irgendwas aber nur weil sie den guten
gedanken nicht goutieren ein
konstruktives gespräch könnte helfen
manchmal haben die ingenieure tolle
ideen das ist gar nicht das problem aber
man müsste eben solche planungsprozesse
wie die energiewende gehen muss man 15
bis 20 jahre geben diese technologien
müssen eine gewisse reife erreichen weil
im flugzeug sagen sie auch nicht
schnittig brothers zusammen es wird
schon fliegen sie müssen da eine
qualität biologie haben das gilt
natürlich auch für die energieproduktion
aber freuen sich die grünen vielleicht
dass wir alle ein bisschen gang
zurückschalten vielleicht ist es absicht
vielleicht ist es ja absicht uns mal ins
messer laufen zu lassen damit wir alle
wie die verrückten jetzt erneuerbarer
energie dem hinterhaus machen und jedoch
nicht gewinnt schraube hinten reinstellt
in der hoffnung dass wir dann begreifen
wie wichtig das ist oder so der weg
zurück wie fand zurück zum lastenfahrrad
das ist auch nicht die stromerzeugung
nein ja aber das ist der wert zurück
jetzt liegt
das mir also die verbots und
regulierungs partei die grünen ich hab
da auch ein paar menschen mit dem ich
mich wunderbar krank verstehen gab es
schon irgendwie erzählen kann ja eben
zum beispiel er hat man mit frau claudia
rothe werden nach über fußball zum
beispiel bei claudia ist eine absolute
fußball fachfrau fan des fc augsburg und
wir haben uns schon also wirklich toll
und dann ich hätte ein schönes bild sie
hat man eine laudatio auf mich gehalten
ich habe einen faschingsorden
vorher und das war dass der nachfolger
die laudatio da hat sie ein lied auf
mich gesungen ich war so gerührt seitdem
sind eine ganz dicke bevölkerung auch
die janitschek der wirtschaftsplan ist
ein gutes spiel von mir auch ich würde
ich im fasching und im fußball auch
tatsächlich eher als jetzt im amt der
bundeskulturstiftung von und dann macht
sie noch am wenigsten kaputt
ja okay jetzt
bin ich da bin ich bei ihnen das war zu
wenig da bin ich voll bei ihnen herr
aber
schon im vorfeld hätte man doch wissen
müssen nicht können was dort aufgebaut
wird was dort mit staatlichen mitteln
was nichts anderes heißt als mit
steuergeldern der bevölkerung aufgebaut
wird das ist doch nicht vom himmel
gefallen da hätte man doch schon vorher
protestieren können aber erst bei der
eröffnung wir sind ja dinge ausgestellt
dieser antisemitisch also da ist nicht
nur verroht natürlich jetzt nicht so gar
nicht so wenige männer sie kriegt dafür
die ihre brüder zu recht alles gutes
ende nichts schmerzlich winter habe ich
mit ihr kann ja ja natürlich also was
mir was mir bei den grünen stinkt ist
diese regulierungs unterbot anteilig tat
es gibt nichts was was man wenn man sich
zusammensetzt wie können wir das besser
machen wir sagen erst einmal die grünen
sagen erst einmal so geht's nicht ja
aber die alternative da fehlt eben viel
und da wäre der dialog miteinander und
gesellschaft natürlich sehr hilfreich
aber da mal lieber untereinander sich
gegenseitig abends beim bier besoffen
quatsch wie toll die idee ist halt
dieser dialog nicht zustande die
parteitage der grünen sind so anstrengen
die vorfeld debatten und gefechte sind
so kompliziert dann haben sie alles
ausdiskutiert sind froh dass er endlich
ein kompromiss gefunden haben und dann
wird die bevölkerung zum ersten mal von
dem tollen vorschlag und dann muss alles
dafür vorne an diskutiert werden wir
kriegen die wirklich er kam beim grünen
löschen
aber es ist ja weniger schon vieles
gesagt worden aber ich sehe da ich sehe
das genauso man kann ja ziele haben und
ich kann man ja auch verfolgen und
malaga oder meinung sein unsere richtung
die wir uns vorgestellt haben ist die
richtige aber ich bin noch mal da wo wir
vorhin waren am ende hat das erfolgt
diese menschen gewählt die politiker und
ich sage mal die meinungen oder die
wünsche oder was auch immer das der
menschen zu vertreten und wenn man
feststellt offensichtlich in diesem
tempo so wie wir es vorhaben
funktioniert es nicht weil einfach
menschen vielleicht darunter leiden der
eine hat probleme im job der anderen
emotionale probleme weil ihm das alles
so schnell geht dann finde ich ist es
entstehen die politiker in der
verantwortung einfach zu sagen stopp das
können wir so nicht durchziehen aber wir
müssen ist dass man es nicht jedem recht
machen kann ist auch sicherlich richtig
aber dann müssen wir das so machen wie
es für die menschen für die wir
verantwortlich sind verträglich ist und
dieses gefühl glaube ich haben wir
allein moment jetzt sehr klar gesagt
herr knop mit blick auf drohende
blackouts
also ich sag mal ich bin ja kein volk
von panikmache aber ich bin durchaus ein
freund davon sich vorzubereiten ich bin
ja auch fußballspieler und wenn man in
eine in einer meisterschaft startet dann
sollte man gut vorbereitet sein dann
sollte man fit sein und dann sollte man
vielleicht auch die muskeln so aufgebaut
haben dass sie die ganze saison über
halten und nicht zur hälfte schlapp
machen deswegen habe ich finde ich ist
da nichts gegen einzuwenden wenn man
sagt ich habe eine camping batterie im
keller und ich habe mir ein
stromgenerator habe ich habe mir das
irgendwann mal gekauft weil ich ja auch
natürlich als comedian oftmals drehe und
so ein stromgenerator oder so eine so
eine camping batterie die kannst du
super gebrauchen wenn ich mit meinem
bruder videos drehen also man daher zwei
fliegen mit einer klappe aber ich bin
ehrlich auch mit dem hintergedanken
sollte was kommt bis das mit sicherheit
nicht verkehrt aber man muss auch immer
dabei sagen dann muss man dabei sagen
ich habe manchmal so eine camping
batterie kostet jetzt irgendwie 5 600
euro ja und es gibt ja auch menschen
sagt man nicht vergessen die haben die
506 euro nicht überall so ich bin
dankbar dass ich dass ich das habe und
das darf man eben auch immer nicht
vergessen und das ist da bin ich jetzt
wieder bei den deine 100 milliarden wo
du mit brunnen und so weiter aber wie
wär's denn mal wenn die regierung sagt
dass man auf wir reden jetzt den ganzen
tag über blackout dann machen wir doch
jetzt mal meinetwegen die generator den
generator zuschlag und jeder kriegt von
der bundesregierung und den gestellt ja
das hören wir dann nicht aber das sind
und warum ist das sind wir schon wieder
im sozialen netz und die bundesregierung
schenkt uns nein
zumindest eine angehende weil problem
ist schuldig mein programm ist das heißt
das festhalten an der ideologie wir sind
in der sackgasse und gebe es nicht jetzt
seien jetzt sagen dann die grüne
ideologie ok dann lasst mal die
kohlekraftwerke noch mal laufen länger
aber atomkraftwerken ein weil habe oder
berge bösen bis jetzt können wir unsere
basis ganz gut noch im griff kriegen
aber wenn man jetzt auch noch
atomkraftwerke verlängern dann haben wir
eh mit den hier im karton jetzt haben
geschlechter besser diversifiziert als
die energieversorgung
welche heute etwas musik in meinen ohren
aber ich möchte trotzdem
fragen wenn jetzt die grünen es sind ja
nicht nur die grünen die atomkraftwerke
verlängern und auch jetzt alles geben
sind die black als überhaupt noch
abzuwenden
das kann ich als politikjournalist nicht
sagen das müssen energie glaube ich
prophezeie robert habeck spricht er
davon und zwar fast jeden tag ist noch
düsterer als ich ja viel hilft uns ja
dinge voraus die ein wirklich
erschaudern lassen ja ist er der neue
lauterbach ist nur bei energie ja ist
neuer brüder grimm der unterschied
zwischen
mittelteil grausam es passierte was
frauen vertragen das sei aber am schluss
gibt es ein happy end haben aber nicht
deshalb
anna-lena lass dein haar herunter
also wir kommen die frage ob blackouts
drohen kriegen wir jetzt auch nicht 100
prozent das gehalt auch sie sich erlaube
die kommen also ist sich sicher das
sehen sie mal das ist doch so wenn sie
die nets habe ich endlich mal hinkriegen
wenn die produktion von kraftwerken
nicht funktioniert wenn sie das nicht
stabil halten können und es fällt unter
50 prozent dann geht auch noch an dann
wird alle reserven reingeschmissen die
noch da ist und wenn es unser 45 45
prozent fällt dann wird alles
abgeschaltet jedes kraftwerk verschluss
und legten nachbarn können auch nicht
offen wir haben zwar ein paar kopplungs
stellen in die netze der anderen aber
wenn wir höchst leistungsstark haben vom
wetter her was haben die auch höchst
leistungsstark die haben nichts
abzugeben und das wollen wir für notfall
gedacht wenn irgendwann mal ein
kraftwerk oder zwei jahre ausfallen dass
man sich da gegenseitig über die grenze
was rüber schiebt das ist doch kein
normalbetrieb das problem ist einfach
veritable da wir hatten im januar schon
zwei tage ohne fremde hilfe von außen
kann ich mehr klar gekommen wären hätten
wir schon unseren blackout gehabt und
dann ist das problem was ich gesagt habe
also wenn es flächendeckend ausfällt
nicht ist ein staat oder so wenn es
flächendeckend ausfällt dann haben sie
das problem das ganze wieder anzukurbeln
das kann tage dauern es kommt drauf an
wie alles dann funktioniert nach und
nach oder sie haben zum beispiel die
netzwerkbetreiber machen verträge mit
alu hüten ob sie die meine halbe stunde
vom netz nehmen können bevor die
schmelze dann weggeschmissen werden muss
halte ich nur geht gerade so damit sind
meine stadt noch versorgen können nicht
abgeben müssen oder so was sie rangieren
jetzt schon machen extra verträge und er
sagt ja von der albertina halbe stunde
dauert länger nicht weil dann kann ich
das alles wegschmeißen es ist so läuft
jetzt inzwischen schon wir sind ja nur
irgendwie die hasen am galoppierenden
gucken überall pflaster draufzukleben
damit etwas spürt